if you've been waiting to get your hands
on home front the revolution it sounds
like you don't have to wait much longer
deep silver and Dan Buster studios have
announced that the game will hit shelves
on May seventeenth in North America and
may twentieth in all other regions
better yet Xbox one owners can register
for a closed beta that kicks off next
month this release date may not come as
a surprise to you because it was leaked
last week the game was originally
supposed to launch sometime in 2015 but
then was delayed to 2016 last year
homefront the revolution takes place in
2029 two years after the events of
2011's homefront protagonist Ethan Brady
returns to lead a resistance movement
against the army of a Korean invasion in
the city of Philadelphia it will feature
a single-player campaign in a four
player online co-op mode despite being
attached to the first homefront game
developer damn buster studios alleges
that everything is new for the game and
that there is a reason why it was not
titled homefront too will you join the
resistance and push back against the
Korean invasion later this year let us
know in the comments below